foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
is that Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
happy holidays
Merry [ __ ] Christmas
[Music]
are we gonna get a national Christmas
gift
I don't know if we are not
I have no idea but today I'm in the
Christmas spirit
I think maybe
you know as much as an atheist who likes
pagan holidays could be oh good morning
to you out there in the country if
you're not snowed in yet there's snow
all across the the Midwest one of our
moderators said it's snowing in Texas so
the world's going to shut down there
um and if the power goes out for
Christmas you know who to blame
oh
I think Greg Abbott may have a shitty
Christmas what do you think
hopefully the power grid stays open for
those people in Texas so they can have a
great Christmas and everywhere we don't
want power outages
we don't want tragic accidents we want a
great holiday so be safe if you're
traveling please be safe if you're
traveling out there if you're in my
audience I want you to be safe do you
like the Hat
it's a crazy hand
I've had it for a long time everyone
asked me where I got it I'm not really
sure where I got it but I'm in the
Christmas spirit today we're going to
try to see if Gabe Sanchez can be in the
Christmas spirit as well
um I'm trying to work on maybe getting a
guest
special appearance
um from someone who knows a little bit
about telling people Merry Christmas or
not we're definitely going to watch the
video uh rather he's able to join us or
not we're going to watch the Christmas
video today is the Christmas special I
guess you call it here at the Tony
Michaels podcast you know we broadcast
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch don't
forget if you're on YouTube right now to
subscribe to the YouTube channels we're
getting a lot of new audience members
a lot of people watching us new on
YouTube a ton of new people on Facebook
now over on Twitch we've got new
supporters new followers so follow us in
all those spots but don't forget to
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod we will have the bonehead of the
week poll this week today
um again
you have to remember tomorrow we're not
gonna have a show
for the Christmas holiday and Monday
will be off as well so we'll be back on
Tuesday after today
uh but we will have the bonehead of the
week poll you'll get the vote for
bonehead of the week we're just not
gonna have a show tomorrow to do
bonehead
but we'll be back strong next week for
bonehead of the week so don't forget
again to go follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod and you can also vote here
on YouTube
on the tubes of you
you just go to the channels hit
subscribe first and then go over the
community tab
and you will find the poll there also
download every single episode Apple
Spotify Google what is ever your
favorite directory make sure you
subscribe and leave a great review while
you're there
checking out our episodes on the
directories Merry Christmas
Merry Christmas
what is the Christmas gift that the
nation wants
what could it be this Christmas stuff
could it be that we
um get more in-depth view of the Cheeto
dust q and honors taxes I I think
that'll probably come next week
you know it's going to take a while for
them to thumb through
how broke he is it's going to take a
little bit we got the report we talked a
little bit about it yesterday with Gabe
Sanchez he actually read through about
half of it I don't know if he's gotten
through the remainder of it now maybe
we'll ask him a little bit about that
today
but we did get some of the transcripts
uh from the January 6 select hearing our
committee excuse me
and the testimony which didn't reveal
much it didn't seem like
I think it was just fifth faith faith V5
foam fifth right I mean that's that's
all they got he was a lot of crime there
was a lot of cooing
they didn't want to self-incriminate on
the Cheeto dust kangaroo coup so there
was a lot of people taking the fifth and
a lot of it was performance right A lot
of it was [ __ ] performance they're
[ __ ] right
these these people don't care about
democracy they don't care about
accountability they don't want to be
held accountable that's why this whole
[ __ ] free speech thing where they
don't understand what freedom of speech
but not freedom of consequences actually
is
they have no [ __ ] clue they believe
it's their white supremacy privilege in
this country to do whatever the [ __ ]
whenever the [ __ ] however the [ __ ] they
want
and no consequence
that's why they did that but hopefully
that report will come out today and we
will see more of the hard evidence
um that may
garnish some wedges to draw remember
we've been talking about this a lot
messaging narrative
how it's important to politicize every
[ __ ] thing to save our democracy well
we're going to keep doing that here
we're going to keep pointing out the
things that you can do to draw those
wedges one of the wedges that's still
being um wedged in and pounded in is
this a little bit of a
Tit for Tat oh maybe I shouldn't use it
it's all Feud
between Lauren Bobo bobert and Marjorie
hooffoot green
and these two were feuding I guess Matt
Gantz is kind of in the middle of it
um do you want him in the middle of
anything I don't think so
so we'll see that's one wedge the other
wedge is Rhonda zantes and Donald Trump
there's another wedge we can draw
but we'll see what this report gives us
to politicize what weapons we can use to
save our democracy because that's what
the January 6 elect committee was all
about folks they always like oh it's all
political it's all yeah it's political
it was a [ __ ] election
it was politicians trying to certify the
vote that the State Certified you
[ __ ] boneheads
the the president of the United States
who lost by eight million votes who was
on his way out
told his political supporters to go stop
the politicians from certifying a vote
that we voted for for our government
yes it's [ __ ] yeah the whole thing all
of it uh every [ __ ] bit of it is
[ __ ] political
all of it
right down to the big [ __ ] lie which
apparently Sean Hannity has admitted in
in under oath and testimony that he did
not believe it for a second
still pushing the big lie though right
it's all performance again we are at the
intersection of WrestleMania in real
life
but that's why we can't let up that's
why we can't let these [ __ ] idiots
control the narrative in the messaging
we have to continue to push [ __ ] them
we could do it with truth they do it
with lies we can do it with the truth
it's not that difficult we did it in
2020 we did it even better in 2022
you know that because we've had Dr
Rachel bittickoffer on this show my
favorite political strategist
probably the smartest political mind
in modern times I'm not kidding you
I know we've had a lot of public
conversations on on on film with Dr
Rachel bittickoffer but I have had
personal private conversations and she
is one of the smartest
political Minds she knows how narrative
Works she knows how messaging works she
knows how to draw wedges
she knows exactly
what we as pro-democracy Coalition
should be doing to make sure to save the
son of a [ __ ]
and we can't we can't shy away from
politicizing things
we can't if we do
[Music]
um
it's not gonna it's not gonna pan out in
our favor we cannot be scared of these
[ __ ] and they always say oh
don't fight fire with fire [ __ ]
someone if someone brings fists to a
fistfight you're gonna fight with your
fist that's what you're gonna do
and it's worth fighting for
one example is Gen Z has come to the
table and shown the country
that they believe in democracy
that they're they're willing to learn
they're willing to fight
they're willing to stand
on that shining city of the Hill
and not let our country
go to fascism
they're not concerned about line items
and bills they understand that we must
win elections then we can do the line
items and bills thing right you don't
get to pass policy you don't get the due
policy if you don't win elections
I mean we we have the prime example
right now in the House of
Representatives
we kicked ass we really did we made sure
there wasn't a red wave we made sure
they did not run Russia on over our
democracy but they still won because
they gerrymandered
these districts and they made sure that
they could hold on to just a little bit
of a majority that way they can have
control over committees but Kevin
McCarthy the majority leader currently
can't get to 218.
and nor can any other politician in
Washington that's how broke their party
is
they don't have one person in their
entire party that can get to 218 and
everyone's standing around wondering why
Donald Trump lost in 2020 and wondering
why Herschel Walker lost
wondering I'm mastriano lost wondering
why Dr Oz carry Lake loss no it it's
because they're [ __ ] boxes
and they're crazies they're [ __ ]
queuing on crazies
and we must take advantage of that
we as a pro democracy Coalition must
take advantage
of these people being out of their minds
we have to point it out we have to make
every single one of them look like
they're just as crazy as [ __ ] Carrie
Lake
and Doug mastriano
just as inept as Dr Oz and Herschel
Walker and Blake Masters we have to tag
every single one of them as the America
First Nazi party
it's working
but we can't stop
we can't let up
we can't stop yelling and screaming
because they're not going to if you
think they're gonna stop talking about
Hunter Biden's dick pics on his laptop
and the January 6 insurrectionist are
political prisoners you're out of your
[ __ ] mind they're gonna come back
around all the good hits too the big lie
CRT
they're gonna come back around to it
socialism
communism I mean they're gonna they're
really gonna dig in
they're not gonna have a choice because
they don't have any substance in their
party
they don't they won't
there is no policy
behind their party
none
and not only do they have no policy they
have no functioning way to govern at all
Kevin McCarthy can't get to 218 as
Speaker
that is his job on a daily basis folks
and Speaker of the House I don't know if
you know this the reason why Nancy
Pelosi is such a good [ __ ] speaker is
because she can whip votes
do you know why you're not Joe Biden is
such an effective president he can whip
votes
what do you think our government is
that's what it is fundamentally it's
representing us
and the only way to change anything
anything
is to whip votes and whip support that's
it whether it's by executive order you
have to have support or it's through the
Congress you have to whip votes and
there is not one Republican in this
country that can get to 218. they can't
even whip enough votes to be the person
who's whipping boots
it is vitally important for any
political party for any government
to be able to get the votes to function
that's why I'm telling you right now
it's December 22nd
2022 and sometime in September I don't
know the exact date because I don't
think we have the CR yet the continuing
resolution bill but sometime in
September depending on what the treasury
does too
we will have a government shutdown
I don't care who the speaker is I don't
give a [ __ ] who it is
they won't be able to whip the votes
and they won't bring it to the floor
there's no way the Republican Party
keeps the government open with
Democratic votes not gonna do it
they'll shut down the government before
they do that
and maybe that's their plan is to blame
it on Kevin McCarthy they're setting him
up
to get just 218 so he'll be the speaker
until he shuts down the government and
they'll blame it on him
because they're gonna have to blame it
on somebody because the American people
are going to blame it on the Republicans
you know why because of us
because us out there yelling and
screaming
and not letting down the narrative not
letting down the messaging that the
Republican party has failed our
democracy
and the one reason why is because
fundamentally they do not believe in
democracy anymore their party has walked
away from it
it doesn't matter if there's a Mitt
Romney or a Liz Cheney or Adam kinzinger
talking about democracy and blah blah
blah yakety schmaggity it doesn't matter
they're not invited to the party anyways
they might as well do what Kirsten
Cinema did and become Independents at
this point
they're not [ __ ] Republicans
Republicans are Nazis if you got an R
next to your name and you're proud of it
you're a [ __ ] America First Nazi
that's what you are
that's how we brand them that's how we
tag them that's how we win
and that's why I keep saying I'm excited
at the prospect of the biggest [ __ ]
loser
in our [ __ ] country being their
nominee again especially when he's under
criminal indictment
and more of them to come
and he's absolutely vulnerable to anyone
in his party that wants to take the man
away from him and he will have to say
the craziest I know you think oh my God
he says crazy [ __ ] right now you have no
idea I'm telling you you got no idea how
crazy crazy can get when this
[ __ ] turns on the chaos machine
and his back is up against the wall and
his only way out is to win an election
he's [ __ ] he's completely [ __ ] and
that is the best Christmas gift
that we can get
we have worked hard since 2015.
to form the narrative in the messaging
to make sure to defeat trumpism but
Trump himself and we have done that time
and time again
we have won yeah he got the presidency
on the technicality in 2016.
but that does not mean he was popular
and we must stay focused
we must stay focused because as much as
he is a threat
it is trumpism it is it is the magas the
maglidites
that small percentage of people in this
country
who are living in a q Anon world
and they're believing the delusion or
they just pretend to believe the
delusion which is even more dangerous
folks
to our democracy when they pretend
because they know
so as you go into the Christmas holiday
and as you travel safely to your family
get-togethers and you
once again sit down with your great old
Maca supporting Uncle Earl
he's the um the head chapter president
of the Facebook Ivermectin Q Anon group
you know who I'm talking about this
[ __ ] gay
you have
to know the messaging you have to know
the narrative
it is vitally important
and we all have to be on the same page
here
we cannot let these weak ass [ __ ]
liberals out there
who who continue to have defeatism as
their
as their personality you know I'm
talking about you know I'd say it all
the time and I don't give a [ __ ] I'll
call them out The Young Turks t-y-t
David Pacman and the like
defeatist even people on CNN MSNBC The
fetest [ __ ] defeatist if any of the
if you watch any pundit anywhere and
they believe the polls for 2022 they are
not doing punditry correctly okay
they're not good commentators they suck
they're terrible at it they want to be
correct they don't care about punditry
they don't care about commentary they
don't understand what messaging and
narrative is they have no idea how do
you think the right wing stole away the
messaging and the narrative in this
country they did it with right wing talk
radio
I've had this comment a lot and I'm open
about it I don't give a [ __ ]
I really don't care
a lot of people have said this show
feels like right wing talk radio it does
because that was intentional
I did that intentionally I do it every
day intentionally
some people have even called me the left
the rushland ball of the left it doesn't
bother me
do you have any idea where we're at
today because of that scumbag
one of the greatest radio talents in the
history of our country and he used it
for nothing but gross vile destructive
undemocratic ideas and pushing the
Republican party faster and faster and
faster to fascism
we can do it too
we can save democracy with the same
ideas
the same the same thing
it really is not complicated that's why
me and Dr Rachel bittick offer get along
so well because we fundamentally believe
that
that yeah may it feel gross sometimes
sure but that's what I'm for
I'm the rodeo clown folks
that's the whole point
you know and they the right Wingers
won't say it like this they won't admit
that that they're part of the circus
they won't say it out loud but what do I
care
doesn't bother me a bit
that's what I'm here for
I'm here to be used
to push the narrative to push the
messaging it's up to you to spread it
around at that point
and share this show
and share the messaging more than
anything that is the most important part
and yeah I know sometimes we act silly
on the show you know look at me I got
the how can you [ __ ] take me
seriously with a goddamn hat on like
this right
like Jesus Christ this [ __ ] gay he's
trying to give us a real political
message and look at the Hat he's got on
again
the rodeo clown you see what I mean do
you see
it isn't complicated I I'm I'm not
embarrassed by it it doesn't bother me a
bit
it's worth saving democracy isn't it to
you
imagine imagine what the holiday season
would look like with this blizzard
coming in for a a big bass part of our
country of the land mass that we have
and fascists taking over everywhere
having no policy no ability to govern
do you think do you think they would
have do you honestly believe that if we
let these megalodites run the entire
[ __ ] country that a snowstorm like
this wouldn't shut down the entire
[ __ ] thing
you think you think they'd have
Provisions you think they'd have backup
plans you think they'd have policies and
and protocol in place no they don't give
a [ __ ] about you I mean they'd have
prayer call for themselves they'd hop on
a plane and go to Cancun
they make sure the power is on at their
Christmas party
that's the whole point
there would be there would be no travel
in this country without policy without
roads
without us the government making sure
those roads are safe where do you think
the [ __ ] salt in those trucks that
are out there cleaning the roads and the
and the people driving those trucks
making a living driving those trucks
making sure our roads are safe for the
holiday season who do you think
who do you think pays for that us the
government
they would call it oh that's big
government
I'm telling you folks
everywhere around you
every part every facet of your life in
this country
the foundation 100 percent
is our democracy rather you want to
believe it
or you think that's not the that's the
truth or not it doesn't matter
fundamentally our country is built on
the foundation of our constitution
every single aspect of our life
the reason why you have the freedom to
travel is because of it
so this holiday season when you're
Gathering up with your with your loved
ones
if if they're if they're good-minded
liberals
who are not who are strong because
liberalism is strong it's not the weak
part of
of ideology
authoritarianism is easy to listen to
One [ __ ] tell you what the hell
you're gonna do
and then do what they tell you you're
gonna do
democracy is tough
that's why Liberals are tough that
[ __ ] where liberals or snowflakes
and leaptards and all that [ __ ]
that's all [ __ ] [ __ ] every last
bit of it now I mean we got our few
right I mean you got dummies
I mean
you're gonna go visit your family
surely surely you got a couple that
you're like ah this is [ __ ] gay he's
[ __ ] gay
Earl over here
Chad whoa Chad let's talk about Chad for
a minute
everyone's got them and our party has
them
but that's you know the beautiful part
about the situation in our country right
now is they have eight only alienated
themselves so much into such a small
percentage
that look how diverse the pro-democracy
Coalition is it really is incredibly
diverse
from all generations
to all colors of skin to religions to
walks of life
to to Absolute where you fall on the the
political Spectrum it is so diverse
and that's why I'm so optimistic
because diversity X p in the majority of
the country
will bring us closer to equity and
equality
it's hard it's difficult we're not going
to get exactly where we want to go in
this generation
that's why it's so important that we
save our democracy now for the future
Generations so they have a chance at
better Equity better equality
it's so important
it's so important so gather up with your
families eat well eat good
and uh smackle Uncle Earl with some cold
hard facts everybody follow us here on
YouTube do not forget to subscribe here
on YouTube we're gonna do the bonehead
of the week poll today as we do every
Thursday you can vote here on YouTube
just go to the community tab we will put
that pull up later on it'll probably be
pretty soon
we may put it up live on the show why
not maybe we'll let you guys help us
pick it out uh at the Tony Michaels pod
on Twitter you can vote there as well
again make sure to download every single
episode of the Tony Michaels podcast
we bring it to you every single weekday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch and we
simulcast from the Midas touch Facebook
page don't forget to follow our page on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels at the
Tony Michaels on Facebook if you're on
the minus touch Facebook Channel right
now listen I want to do one more thing
before I go to break I want to thank
my moderators
they are the best minor and I know I
keep saying this but they are the best
moderators in the world give them all
sorts of love
and holiday spirit uh they they have
worked so hard this year
um and helping us make sure because we
have had more and more Chatters and they
keep telling me and I apologize to them
they keep telling me to to turn on slow
mode because there's so many comments
you guys you guys come with the comments
so fast that we've had to add moderators
and they still can't keep up
and that they love it I know they love
it they love the engagement they love
the conversation the [ __ ] em fam is
strong
we have we have our our hate Watchers we
love having them we we have our greatest
fans and you guys come here every single
day and you're talking in the chat with
each other
and it's encouraging that's what keeps
me going I'm not able to read the chat
anymore because it goes so fast but you
guys are fantastic the best audience in
the world and you have the best
moderators in the world in the chat
so go give some love to all the
moderators here at the Tony Michaels
podcast wish them a happy holiday
everyone we have to be safe we have to
be vigilant for our democracy don't go
anywhere don't don't hit the dial as
they'd say on the television don't
change the channel as they'd say on the
radio we'll be right back
right after these messages
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] them Buckle [ __ ] em [ __ ] em [ __ ] em
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
it's beginning to look a lot like
Christmas
[Music]
who else has got snow on the ground out
there
[Music]
oh
I don't know do you like snow I'm not a
fan I'm not a [ __ ] fan I could do
without it right I could do without the
[ __ ] snow
I I mean you want to put it on like a TV
screen or something like that yeah great
it looks great in pictures oh the winter
walking in a winter wonderland that's
fine
it's fine the music's fine
you know I know but I don't want to deal
with the snow do you want to deal with
the snow I don't want to deal with the
snow
I don't
but it is a thing that we are all gonna
do it seems like because it's not just
going to affect and again I go back to
policy and having people in charge that
are [ __ ] just just decent and
competent and a bare minimum
that this is going to affect travel all
over the country it's not just going to
affect where the storm is
because it's a busy travel time as you
all know
for the weekend so absolutely it's going
to affect the entire country and the
travel in the entire country
so
having people in charge of [ __ ] that
give a [ __ ] about being in charge of
[ __ ]
it matters it [ __ ] matters
but you know who am I who am I to say
let's see what the comments say uh let's
go to the comments it's a it's a
Christmas it's a Christmas
season
oh here we go
um foggy Ozark G
are you Tony I moved from Missouri to
Missouri from Kansas I don't know if
you're in the Ozarks to get away from
too cold and too windy I can do without
the 60 mile an hour winds it is windy
here where I'm at in Missouri it's very
windy very cold the snow is coming down
um I don't know how long it's supposed
to last I think for another three hours
or so
um I went out to see if I could do some
Christmas shopping yes it's typical I'm
a [ __ ] man I waited to the last
minute and it's beginning to get
difficult to find what I'm looking for
but I did go out this morning and before
it got too snowy and before the show to
try to see if I could find some
Christmas gifts I was unsuccessful but
the roads were a little slick they had
not put a lot of stuff down yet and
there wasn't a lot of snow so they
couldn't scrape it off
so I'm with you foggy I don't I mean you
know cold doesn't bother me I just don't
want the [ __ ] I don't want the
[ __ ] snow now let's see what other
comments do we get who else has snow out
there
let's see
and and oh Marie glazes you guys are
thank you very much very much and MJ
says our pleasure she must be talking to
someone in the chat maybe she's she's
getting all kinds of Love MJ's one of
our moderators so give the moderators
some holiday holidays live
in the chat we love our moderators here
he's really
MJ's MJ's gonna be uh mad at me that I
didn't slow down the chat you guys are
are going pretty fast here I need to put
it on slow moan I figured that out I
think each episode we have to do MJ I'm
not sure
um I know I couldn't find it the other
day when I was looking for it to set
every single one automatically to be in
kind of slow-mo
we'll see we'll see uh she says Marie it
says I'm feeling the Hat Tony you like
the Christmas hat I mean we got the
[ __ ] pants right everyone knows the
[ __ ] hands what the [ __ ] and if you
wanna [ __ ] a man you can go to the Tony
michaels.com and you can see the Hat
link you can't get one of these
Christmas hats so I've had it for a long
time again I'm not sure exactly where I
got it
I only bring it out for the Christmas
season
it's got the Reindeer and the Santi
claws anyone who's listening to the show
today should go um uh check out YouTube
and see my hat everyone loves this hat
we went to a Christmas parade
um this year and I was I was walking my
daughter was on a float
on the Christmas parade so I had to get
pictures right so I was walking up and
down the street and they kind of did a
circle so I was like walking all over
the place and as I was walking around I
had my hat on and I had a hoodie because
it was It was kind of cold and people
were not paying attention to the parade
like man that's a cool hat well where'd
you get the Hat yeah so I try not to
wear it out and about because I get it
gets you think I like attention like
that but then
I I really I I like to go Incognito if I
can
um but they love the hat they love the
hat uh Jennifer says best hat winner
if I can get it up here there we go best
at winner on Facebook Jennifer says she
likes the Hat on Facebook
let's see what other comment we're
waiting on Gabe Santa we're waiting on
Gabe Sanchez where are you
Sanchez
I wonder if he's going to um he's going
to be in the Christmas spirit this
morning what do you guys think you think
he's gonna have a Christmas hat on a
Christmas sweater do you think he'll
just be normal old Gabe what do you
think you think he's going to be in the
holiday spirit
hmm what do you think
I think I think Gabe Sanchez is going to
have some holiday holiday cheer that
he's going to bring us today
I believe so I'm also waiting to see if
we're going to get this um
guest on I want to show a video some
videos that he did about Christmas
um I don't want to give too much away I
want to kind of and you guys have
probably seen him but I I've been
holding off I've actually been holding
off showing you guys these videos for
today's episode because we will not have
an episode tomorrow this is the last
episode before Christmas so we wanted to
have like a Christmas type episode it's
where I'm why I'm wearing this goofy hat
my my Christmas Santa sweater
is we wanted to have a a Christmas
episode I guess you'd say so I these are
Christmas videos so I've been holding
off for almost a week
I think he put these out
um over a week ago so I but I'm again
I've been not showing them
for the reason I'm showing you today so
everyone's loving the hand see I told
you
Everyone likes the Hat Everyone likes a
hat
let's see Escape Sanchez here yet and
where is he where is Gabe Sanchez
again everyone give the moderators in
the chat it is the Christmas episode so
give them some special love
they've done a great job this year and
they deserve a ton of Love they I I I
can't say enough
I can't say enough and they're always
they're always on top of me right they
they are on top of stuff they Point
stuff out I miss a ton of things
and they're always trying to make sure
that we get where we need to be and
that's why they're the best moderators
in the world so
um Margie one of our moderators here
says [ __ ] em fam love
we love the [ __ ] them fam here that was
I don't know MJ was that you who coined
that someone coined it the [ __ ] fam I
believe it was our moderator MJ MJ has
been watching the show since the very
beginning
like long long ago when I used to do it
once a week did you guys know that I did
this show once a week and it was one
hour
and it was just me talking as if now
it's not literally just basically me
talking
but it was just me talking for a full
hour we did it on Wednesdays we did it
later in the afternoon
and then when Gabe Sanchez came on as
executive producer and co-host
we decided to change it up we changed
the time we went to two hours once a
week and then
at the beginning of this year we went to
every single weekday for two hours
Monday through Friday and I know Amanda
she's been here for a long time too
watching Amanda's
she's she's probably here three hours
three hours almost every day she wants
us to do three hours which I would love
to do three hours I would love to do
three hours and we'll get there we'll
probably get there eventually
um it's just a matter of feasibility we
gotta have more hands on deck to do a
full three hours it's probably it's easy
for me to talk you guys know that Jesus
Christ I could talk for 10 hours to you
people every single day just sit here
and Yap we'd watch videos together
we would we dig in on the American first
Nazi party make sure to mock them a bit
but again
again
it's just not quite feasible yet we'll
get there the mighty librarian she says
10 hours yeah yeah yeah 10 hours you
know uh Hassan [ __ ] son Abby over on uh
his twitch stream he he does like six or
eight hours a day now the dude takes
like bathroom breaks he's eating on he's
eating and stuff like that
so it's not quite set up like our show
where we do kind of a radio show like
that's kind of what you know you know I
mean you're watching it but that's kind
of the feel right is the radio show
but he does a twitch stream for a long
time like all day long and nearly like
six seven days a week I'm like Jesus
Christ I thought I talked a lot
some other people are saying um
Sue Sue here on uh on YouTube is trying
to compromise come on Tony just two and
a half hours now if you noticed on
Fridays with bonehead of the week
for whatever reason I think it's just
because there's so much [ __ ] that we got
to talk about and then we add bonehead
of the week onto the show on Fridays
and again tomorrow we will not have bone
end of the week because we are off
tomorrow and Monday we'll do the poll
today so you'll be able to vote but we
won't actually have the video next week
we'll be back full force with bonehead
of the week but you've noticed on
Fridays that bonehead of the week has
put us at almost two and a half hours
so I mean there's plenty of content to
mock these fools to talk about to
commentate on
to give you the narrative to give you
the messaging that you need to go out
and you know tell Uncle Earl the [ __ ]
off
but it's just it's the feasibility it's
the feasibility because uh trust me we
do not get that big old George Soros
check like people think we do
we do not that's not a thing George
Soros does not give me any money to do
this this is not a money making venture
it isn't it isn't now you could support
by going to the Tony michaels.com
thetonymichaels.com if you want to
support you can go there there's merch
there uh you you can leave a tip you can
you can go follow us on all social media
you can send those links to your family
your friends get them to listen get them
to watch
maybe just a day or two a week they
don't have to watch every single day
they'll catch they'll catch the majority
of the messaging
that's how we do
uh Michelle here on on YouTube says
three hour Texas Taco Tuesday so uh
Michelle likes when we have Texas Paul
on on Tuesdays I'm assuming that's what
she's what she's talking about that's
that's one of my favorite days too look
I I love the bonehead of the week
segment it's fantastic it's fun you guys
get to vote so you get say in it we get
to interact we get we get to we get to
engage with the poll the other thing too
is it kind of sets us up for production
so like whatever you guys choose that's
kind of our production yeah you know it
it produces itself in other words
because we have our reasons why we're
putting them on you vote then we and
then we it makes a 45-minute show our 45
minute segment easy pretty much
but that's one of my favorite but one of
my favorite days here is Tuesday because
we get to have Texas Paul here
now we had um this Tuesday and I forgot
about this the other day when I was
talking to Gabe Sanchez in a private
chat
um we had um
Texas Paul on Tuesday but Gabe wasn't
able to make it
um he had some appointments and stuff he
had to keep so it was just me and Texas
Paul and I don't know if we've ever done
that does the moderators know
have we ever done just me in Texas Paul
I don't know I I couldn't say
um it gets away from me like these
things run
um you know they kind of mash up
together I I can't hardly
keep track of each day it's hard
yeah see um the moderators are even
saying can we slow down the chat let me
see if let me see if I can slow down the
chat
let's see if I can I can figure it out
here probably not I'm just not
um
I know there's a way to slow it down I'm
not that advanced I swear everyone
thinks that I've got this
tech knowledge but what do you think I
got Gabe Sanchez for huh what do you
think I've got Gabe Sanchez for he's my
he's the tech person
oh slow mo there we go okay
all right I think I got it moderators
I slowed it down a bit
slowed it down a bit I don't know if
that'll help if it hurts let me know
if it's too long
um people are asking where is Gabe I
don't know let me let me see let me see
let me ask him chat is asking
where you are I kind of like Today's
show you know it's more laid back we're
gonna go on Christmas break we're
talking to the chat too slow MJ says
okay I'll speed it up a bit I'll speed
it up a bit
let's do this uh let's do a 10. how's
that we'll try we'll try 10 seconds
uh MJ says the chat is too slow
too long MJ says
so um
I again I kind of like the uh I kind of
like the laid back feeling for today
I don't know what do you guys think
too slow try every 15 seconds Susan B
said
it did I got slow moaned on now I said
it what I said it I said it 10. 10
seconds
10 seconds what does it mean slow mode
does that mean like
does that mean you can you you can't
uh send a message but every 10 seconds
is that what it means Margie says 10 is
perfect
for right now
right now it's perfect I guess
you know slow is good it's hard to keep
track listen
it's been almost two years
I've had this show for two years and
when I first started doing this show
there was like three people watching I'm
not kidding you the three maybe four
people would show up most the people
were from Tick Tock because that's kind
of how I started was with tick tock and
and there wouldn't be a lot of people
show up for the show and it just grew
and grew and grew and MJ can tell you
yeah here's MJ MJ said she was one of
them like literally literally it was MJ
and three other people
watching
and I just talk for an hour
and people and it's built to what it is
now we have to slow it down to where you
can't comment
every 10 but every 10 seconds
and that's how this works like this is
lit that's that's what I'm trying to do
is trying to show
that the pro-democracy coalition
can have simple messaging we do not need
a complex message we do not need a big
huge complex uh oh my God
oh
[ __ ] uh everyone uh Gabe said she has
just came in the green room and um
oh [ __ ] I thought I was dressed up I
thought I was decked out here I'm just
I'm just wondering where the [ __ ] the
beard is where is the beard uh I I don't
I don't have the beard I just shaved so
I it's all gone you know oh oh but if
you had you would dye it white right
right exactly if I could is that a beard
on your shirt yeah yeah oh okay okay so
you do have the beard yeah yeah so it's
just trying the actual beer yeah okay
okay look look at look look at that yeah
you know in the creek I got the the
lights going on in the back here you
know
oh my God merry Christmas happy holidays
and a happy Christmas are you doing
something special for Christmas
uh
um yeah yeah okay so I'm going I'm going
to my uh my girlfriend's family's house
this year I mean we do we're gonna just
do it every year because it's so
expensive you know that sounds like it's
getting pretty serious you know what I
mean it is it's pretty serious okay well
good well good that's good to hear
that's good to hear but it's uh is it
well you wouldn't want to fly into
Chicago uh no right now anyways no not
at all not at all yeah yeah this is but
it's also one of those things where uh
it's so expensive to fly back during the
holidays right so going from the West
Coast it's cheaper to fly from the west
coast to the east coast than it is from
the west coast to the Midwest right
right it is it is well right now right
now if you're on a plane or plan on
being on a plane and going to the
Midwest today this afternoon it is not
going to be fun oh yeah I had friends
who were flying who were flying from La
back home to Chicago yeah and they
luckily got out yesterday oh well that
day was a whole different story it would
be a [ __ ] nightmare oh yeah at St
Louis Kansas City Kansas City just I
mean it just rolled through Kansas City
now Marty was saying it was snowing in
Texas I'm like oh [ __ ] oh yeah so and
and I was saying before that like
the plane travel thing but also the the
roads and everything this this affects
the entire country I mean you're not
traveling number one because of the cost
but I'm sure there's a lot of people
that are going to be like [ __ ] that I'm
not going yeah today because I mean it's
just going to be a madhouse yeah I I
can't uh I can't imagine
trying to travel in this just like [ __ ]
show of uh
I'll make hold on I gotta step out I'll
come back right back hold on yeah
okay he had to leave he had to leave I
don't know maybe he's maybe he's getting
more uh more costumes going I don't know
what we were talking about before Gabe
sanjays showed up in his his uh his
Santa outfit there I forgot I don't know
whoosh what an outfit what an outfit see
I knew he would come he would come in
the spirit I knew he would I knew he
would oh here here and um minus Robin
has a she's a great moderator here too
give Robin some love and she says find
all things Gabe here
is link tree and there's the link to
Gabe's link tree so go go follow Gabe on
all his channels also I don't know if
you guys know this I know we push our
podcast here
on the Tony Michaels podcast of course
we want you to download it but did you
know
did you know you can go download the
audio version
of what was that
you know the great segment that Gabe
Sanchez does it's all it's on the Midas
touch Network he puts it over there in
video form you can download it you just
go to Gabe's linktree Robin's got the
link right here linktree slash I am Gabe
Sanchez and you can actually download on
a podcast if you if you prefer listening
to podcasts you can download the what
was that on every single episode that he
puts out
you can go download them on
on Apple's Spotify Google I think he's
got it on all of them but you can
download the what was that so go to go
to Gabe Sanchez's linktree
and um subscribe to his what was that
and it's a great segment great segment
thanks for
reminding us where to go there Robin is
the is the chat going at the right speed
well let's see
let's see if I could do that
I think it's gone at the right speed
it's going at the right speed how are we
out there
I was speeding up
[Music]
oh yeah here's Texas Paul's too don't
forget to go check out Texas Paul Texas
Paul's here every Tuesday here's his
link tree miss loveseek another great
moderator has his link here
Margie says it's perfect so that must
mean
that the chat
set at 10.
for slow is perfect it's fantastic I
don't know where the hell Gabe Sanchez
went I have no idea
I really don't know
I wish I knew hmm
let's see here's what we're gonna do
let's do this let's go to the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends let's surf some
Twitter while we're waiting on Gabe
Sanchez to come back maybe he had some
technical difficulties or something I
don't know he's been working out some
new some new things over there so let's
do this let's go to the [ __ ] let's Round
Up start the countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I got the camera situation fixed I
just had to replace the battery thing
because I'm getting a problem last
Friday it was like flickering in and out
and so now I just decided to say [ __ ]
the webcam and now I'm using a DSLR of
mine did you ever figure out what
happened with your webcam is it just it
just wore out I don't know see here's
the thing he probably is using this
webcam way too much he's on the show
here every day and then he's got to do
his only fans and it's just I mean look
cameras
trying to put the content in so that we
can be verified models that's that's
true that's true let's talk about that
for a second yeah so um as the audience
knows we've mentioned this before I have
inquired I actually set up an account I
actually have an account but it's not a
model account yet this is a user account
I didn't know that new years I did not
have a user account on PornHub I was
just I was just a lurker yeah just uh
yeah yeah I didn't have in a visual
account actually until just the other
day so I now have an official account at
PornHub you can go I I guess you go to
pornhub.com and Slash and detail wait
after the show to do that
why
oh I'm on the show I don't want to get
distracted oh
are you getting sidetracked yeah I know
yeah I might listen I don't have any
content on this on this no no I'm not
saying your content before I get to you
know I'm gonna yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna
type in your name and it's gonna say hey
do you want to check out these other
people who are actual models and I go I
don't know I mean might as well you want
to see boobage yeah yeah you know and
Gabe Sanchez is like
um
if the views help them get paid [ __ ] it
I'll help support them yeah that's right
that's right we got well that's that's
mainly why I go to Pornhub is to support
content creators yeah yeah and I mean
all I just play in the background you
know just want to get it right hey you
just want to make sure that the content
creators get you know their you know
make a living that's all I'm trying to
do everyone gets the money Prosperity
that's right
um you know
it has nothing to do with the content
itself I just want to support yeah yeah
the Creator independent creators who's
your favorite porn star who is it uh
uh look at him he's like oh my God he
was not expecting on that he was not
expecting on the Christmas show today
are you looking her up no no no no it's
uh I just want to make sure I was like
all right which one between these two ah
the one the one that I would say is Lisa
Ann but I think she's retired now so she
does like a she has a lot of sports
shoes I think she's just like oh that's
right yeah she moved into sports podcast
yeah yeah yeah uh she I remember one
she she played years you know in all
kinds of years ago years ago she played
uh Sarah Palin because there's a whole
Sarah Palin like Barack Obama one yeah
the whole thing huh yeah
interesting yeah but I think right now
she's retired and she just does like
business business stuff and yeah and
stuff yeah well she's got it she's got a
um really big Instagram I believe I
think she's got a lot of course she just
did a video you know what she just did a
video with uh
there's this
hold on
really and by the way I want the
audience to know that we're not we don't
kink shame we don't porn shame sex work
is work baby uh no she did it she did a
video she's been hanging out with young
gravy who young gravy he's a he's a a
rap artist oh okay okay but they did
they went on a date together and they
hung out and all this stuff but he's
also I didn't I didn't know this and I
didn't know who he was until I saw a
video on Instagram and there were a
bunch of people throwing bras on stage
and I was like what the hell is going on
it turns out that uh he is support he's
receiving
um bras to donate to women in need and I
was like oh [ __ ] that's awesome
I don't know I don't know if it's if
it's women who are buying bras how do
you get a ticket to his show I'm just
hey you know I'm just wondering
yeah well I know but I mean
I don't know I don't know I don't know
but look at the end of the day I was
like oh that's a pretty cool that's like
a pretty cool thing that you're
that you're doing
uh it looks like somebody doesn't want
us to talk about this anymore they're
asking for us to go back to the news oh
they don't want to talk about porn on
the Christmas show today today is a
special Family Values
family oh is that well no no you're
looking for family values you're at the
wrong spot I get that a lot they're like
man if you would just if you would just
tone it down on the cussing like are you
serious do you not listen to anything
that I do and like what the [ __ ] like
how in the hell I wouldn't be who I am
without a couple cuss words peppered in
also you find that you know people who
swear and say the f word they do [ __ ] a
lot they tend to be more uh truthful and
honest and uh oh so it's tied to
truthful honesty and integrity yeah
that's what they say I thought I thought
it was Intelligence but you know yeah
and then you know maybe I don't know it
probably is too I
know dude
where do these studies come from anyways
he's sitting around they're like like
you know what we should figure out if
the word [ __ ]
uh is any indication of someone's
honesty and truthfulness and integrity
like yeah that's a great idea how would
we test if the word
this is uh I don't know what this is it
says people who curse a lot yeah
uh tend to be smarter funnier and
healthier oh I don't know about that but
yeah I mean I don't know if anyone's
ever just like yelled [ __ ] out you know
while they're in there just just to be
healthy just yeah they're like a
visceral like [ __ ] you're like in the
gym [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] exactly yeah though I
I've done that and I've definitely had a
gym manager come by and be like sir
we're gonna happen you're gonna yeah
you're gonna have to you're gonna tone
it down [ __ ] out that's why we have our
own show here though that's why we have
our own show and that's why we're
partnering with the minus touch Network
because they don't they don't tell us
what the hell to do and frankly
I actually believe that they may not
watch the show because they know I'm
saying some crazy [ __ ] just so they're
like there's no I don't want to know
what he's saying right he's so crazy
better that I right no right what you
don't really can't hurt you plausible
diability all right it's not a room I
did not hear I don't know what was that
right it's the whole tree falling in the
woods thing right exactly if no one's
around I mean he still said it but no
one was around to hear it
there's a lot of people around I
actually I figured out
um the moderators are saying I slowed it
down to 10 seconds in slow mode oh yeah
the problem is we had to do it on each
episode so I'm probably gonna have to
you're gonna have to remind me for a
while until I get in the habit and I'm
talking to the moderators you're
probably gonna have to remind me until I
can actually get in the habit of going
because once I create it right because I
gotta create each stream and then I
gotta go in and edit some things and
there's a whole list of things that I do
here that's why sometimes
um we don't sometimes like we have to
show up at um like 30 minutes before
sometimes 20 minutes more mainly it's
because of a game Sanchez because we're
waiting on uh yeah well someone is two
hours ahead of me so I I wake up and
then I gotta start making time travel
time tap trying time travel is a [ __ ]
but here's the thing is that some
mornings he's up and Adam right and he's
got the thumbnail and he and he's always
like I always message him I'm like
thumbnail question mark That's like the
start to the more morning and he's like
what's trending I'm like I don't know go
to Twitter I'm on the [ __ ] looking at
my messages what what do you want from
me so so we figure out what our title is
going to be but the other day this
happened to sometimes it changes like we
got it we know what we're gonna do that
was the nft one right yes it was the
trading cards yeah they dropped and the
video dropped and we were like well we
gotta go with this and that was like
five minutes
right and you know the whole show was on
that yeah the whole show so that's why
sometimes
um we have the show like with the
thumbnail and on YouTube like 30 minutes
before sometimes it's right before
bonehead of the week is the same way too
there's been times like I'm doing my 30
minute thing
and Gabe Sanchez is in the background
message me hey who's the dishonorable
mention in the alpha cook
like we're deciding these things yeah
those two sometimes sometimes it's
pretty clear and then other times it's
literally moments before and you're like
oh this thing just happened like minutes
ago and sometimes I don't even know who
it's gonna be until I load them in and
bring them up yeah like I don't even
know that's why that's why when when you
see me ask Gabe on the bonehead like why
is this why is this person because
literally I don't know why they're on
bonehead of the week sometimes
that's what this show is is we're doing
it it's live baby
not only that but like we're we're doing
it Friday and you had since Monday to go
through a whole medley of boneheads and
that's like a year ago in politics right
from Monday to Friday yeah it's a very
very long time here we are Wednesday
right our this is Thursday Jesus Christ
yesterday yesterday I thought it was
later in the week it was Wednesday and I
was like because that's because we don't
have the episode because I said earlier
in the week and you're like you mean two
days ago Monday yeah yeah that's right
that's right that's right but here's the
thing is
is
we're we're at Thursday right yeah but
it's see and today we're gonna get more
of this um the the the January 6th
select committee's report I guess there
was a bunch of um and I know this is
what the audience wants us to talk about
there's a bunch of the uh uh testimony I
guess some of that and it and it showed
that they just said the fifth because
they're [ __ ] weak cowards I mean
that's what Fifth Fifth and so yeah all
these people who are like oh I'm it's
the same this goes and I just want to
call out this because we'll probably get
into it but like Lauren bober all these
other people who are like you know
[ __ ] uh Thomas Massey and other
people taking video of themselves
outside the capitol or tweeting
or not standing or sitting during the
speech for zielinski but all of these
people what I learned if anything from
zelenski's visit to to DC was the fact
that all of these Republicans
showed that again they are complete
cowards they would rather post a video
critiquing or criticizing or talking
[ __ ] or posting on Twitter be like I'm
not gonna vote for any more money or
this or that or whatever but if they
would never never I guarantee it ever
say those things directly to his face
and say hey
I don't [ __ ] care that the people in
your country are getting killed by a
[ __ ] dictator Putin in Russia so I'm
not going to give you any more money
I can't see none of them couldn't even
have the decency to [ __ ] pay
attention yeah to zelinski when he was
speaking to Congress and she made a
video last night where she was like oh
yes the things that are happening
Ukraine are terrible and he's just
trying to protect his country in the
Border
yeah I think it was after she posted a
video can you find that I'm gonna find
the one where she's where she's uh she's
just sitting there looking at her
goddamn phone oh her and Matt Gates yeah
well you know she's probably looking at
the um the stuff Matt Gates is venmo and
her or whatever and I don't know what
the [ __ ] they do
um but speaking of which like she I mean
I don't I'm sure we'll watch the uh the
Jeffrey's video too but just like the
Jeffrey's video I man I honestly I'm
already so that's the first that's the
first video that's the first video I
sent you right there is uh King Jeffries
I'm talking about the infighting that
has continued and then uh here's here's
a here's a picture from the speech you
can see Lauren bobert here staring at
her phone yeah
um and Matt Getz
he seems like he's like I just sent her
a good a good one I sent her part of
Hunter by his laptop
[ __ ] idiot
um so then there's a video Everybody
yeah so if you go to the second link the
bobert one okay
is this the Tweet she's in there yeah
this is her tweet that she sent out her
response to president zielinski's
address to Congress
this should be fantastic by the way I'm
sure this is just filled with
intelligence okay let's let's listen to
[ __ ] here let's listen
hey everyone I just finished attending
the address by President zielinski and
we're gonna have votes here at the
capitol for the next four hours or so
here's what was clear from tonight the
people of Ukraine are suffering the war
is deadly and horrific and the Carnage
has not stopped sadly what I didn't hear
tonight was a clear explanation of where
the first 50 billion dollars we sent to
support their efforts went until
Congress receives a full audit on where
our money has already gone I will not
support sending additional money to this
war president zielinski is working to
protect his country's border and his
people I get it I really just wish our
commander-in-chief would do the same
right here at home and secure our
Southern border and protect our people
so which is it does she want an audit or
does she want Biden to go down to the
Border or whatever not only that but of
all people who's going to complain about
getting an audit
Lauren bobert the woman who uh
artificially inflated the amount of
expenses that she had traveling from the
from Rifle Colorado to [ __ ] the
capital or whatever and the amount of
expenses that she had while she was ever
you know like there literally got called
out for and she was like oh my mistake
it was just a it was just a simple error
my bad that's not what it was the fact
that she had twenty thousand dollar Plus
in Loan in liens against her business
she ended up losing her business she
wasn't the landlord was like no I will
not uh re-up your your stay here for the
lease you know of all people who's like
I want an audit let's [ __ ] it let's
audit Lauren bobert all of these people
are super pissed that all of a sudden
these Trump tax returns have been
released and now their whole narrative
about Trump being a victim and he was
politically targeted by the by the left
and all the stuff only to be proven
completely wrong and shown that yes this
guy is a [ __ ] fraud he's a liar was
never audited despite saying he was
audited his own IRS decided you know
what we won't audit this guy I wonder
how that happened right exactly
corrupt yeah and even with all these
things you had the right being like oh
no no we don't need to do this he's
under audit audit this under the UK fine
you want a [ __ ] audit let's audit
your stuff let's audit everyone both on
the right both on the left I don't
[ __ ] care I would love for that stuff
to be transparent yeah
the yellow Branch conference like what
happens if we audit the Supreme Court
Justice's taxes like why the [ __ ]
wouldn't we yeah I mean don't maybe
maybe that's the problem maybe that's
the [ __ ] problem you know who's
probably not going to pay taxes for
2022. you know he's probably not going
to pay any taxes because they Trump so
much [ __ ] money well that but I'm
talking about them oh Mr Twitter here
holy [ __ ] did you see this this is
yeah
23. when I know what it is right now oh
no uh this is just about a half hour ago
well it's about 40 minutes ago let's see
that's the stock price
124. so it's right there it's down it's
down 13 for the day but remember if we
go back even six months Jesus
I love it I [ __ ] love to be quite
honest with you I could care less if
Tesla [ __ ] just tanks and there's no
Teslas out there I honestly could not
give a [ __ ] my wife on the year the year
to date like it's like 69 it's 16
69.60 but even if you go back to April
when he started this whole thing oh yeah
yeah when he did the whole joke I'm
gonna bad twitter down
65 almost 66 because where it started at
was
like 380 and now he's down to 120 am
well and the thing is is he sold a
shitload of that stock as it was tanking
yeah that listen for anyone out there
who wants to know how being a
billionaire Works they do not sell
[ __ ] stock at the lowest [ __ ]
price unless they have to because
they're broke he's not that he was never
the richest man in the world because
honestly this richest man in the world
[ __ ] it was hinged upon how how [ __ ]
how what the price of Tesla was and
really we know now that even though he's
tanking it it wasn't worth that because
the market is the market is reflecting
its actual value now right um you know
it was over inflating it before you know
the [ __ ] actually exposed that he's a
[ __ ] idiot well you also I mean if
you remember right this is all you
people need to remember what the price
of Tesla was before the pandemic and why
the price went so what what was it
before the pandemic so if we go back to
March of 2020 right right before it had
right before it happened yeah we'll say
we'll say end of February because that
was when it was like on the uptick right
that's what everyone's like whoa this is
going to really affect her it was six
dollars on on February 21st 2020. now
obviously in the middle of March when
everything kind of hit the [ __ ] fan
uh it dropped down to 28.50 well how'd
it go from 60 to 380
so at that point then you've got people
obviously people buying in low right
they're like oh well these industries
are going to be around for a while uh
you had people there I think there was
like a stock split on on that or uh at
one point
um
and then uh
you had all these other things that were
like as as there were updates happening
with the company and with the technology
of the vehicles and new ones being
released or plans they were like great
great great and it kept going up and I
think a lot of people too
um looked at electric vehicles even more
as an alternative
um during the pandemic and so be from
that point and there's other other kind
of factors that go into it but from that
point they went from 32 dollars yeah and
I think I don't know if there's just one
stock split that happened board two but
again it's just like incredibly over
valued stock is what happened and then
they the height of it and the other
thing too people don't know this there's
a term I think it's called Tesla Tesla
Tesla
um Tesla millionaires
oh so this is people who bought in low
and and yeah teslaneers is a term that
was created because people who bought in
during the pandemic or low and then
or even before that and then have the
stock Skyrocket split Skyrocket again
and again and again uh these people were
made millionaires like within a few
months period And so when you look at
the stock at its highest point which was
400 and that was back in November of
2021 since then it's gone down had
another peak in April of 2022 at 360.
uh and then at that point was when the
whole Twitter kind of like I'm gonna buy
it I'm not gonna buy it [ __ ] I have to
buy it you know and then like let me
just really [ __ ] run into the ground
and because of that he's been selling
stock like a madman on Tesla telling
people no no I won't sell any more stock
I won't sell anything yeah we watched
that yesterday only to sell more stock
recently it sounds like people at
um
people at he's a line sack of [ __ ] yeah
yeah I mean he really is and and really
I it's amazing to me and he must really
have the votes on the board I mean he
must have it lacked with friends or
family or something you think they'd
save him here from his own demise but
they're not doing it
um which I mean honestly I hope that
[ __ ] goes completely [ __ ]
broke I mean just not only torches the
the wealth that he built right uh over
this Tesla thing and really SpaceX and
all the other because we we gave him a
lot of his wealth with SpaceX because
our government [ __ ] subsidizes that
[ __ ] right his [ __ ] rocket said he takes
to space but here's the thing
is the money that I wanted to lose is
the Silver Spoon money oh baby yep
that's when it real that's like because
that's what Donald Trump did that's why
this [ __ ] is desperate because
he lost the Silver Spoon money like what
the [ __ ] are you doing I mean how could
you be so inept but literally if you're
handed a half a billion dollars 500
million dollars right from your daddy
because he had real estate deals and you
[ __ ] that up well you deserve to lose
everything
if you looked at it was like yeah 400
500 million dollars that his dad gave
right to him Trump right and if you look
at what you could make on the market he
would easily have
by just letting the money sit in the
market
but instead do nothing just and shut up
and just exactly and that's what that is
what is so
funny about all of these people all of
these people are like I'm rich and I
have this money that's [ __ ] great but
what you have proven to us is that when
you are given money
right instead of saying hey look I don't
really have to do much I can make an
investment here or an investment there
and kind of play the mark and see what
happens put my money into a [ __ ] fund
somewhere I can give it to someone to
really make me a ton of money and I can
live off that alone just on the interest
but here's just the [ __ ] interest
alone some of these some of these really
wealthy individuals like Warren Buffett
and Bill Gates
like they spend part of their life
acquiring this wealth and then Warren
Buffett and Bill Gates spend another
part of life giving that [ __ ] away
because they know you can't take this
with you and realistically Bill Gates
and Warren Buffett know the market well
enough that they're if if they give
their kids a bunch of [ __ ] money
they're gonna do okay if they're not
boneheads and if they're boneheads [ __ ]
them like Elon and Trump but here's the
thing is even even Jeff Bezos as much as
people hate that [ __ ] recently
he's given he gave Dolly Parton a
shitload of money I don't remember the
exact amount I think it was like 150
million or something I don't remember
exactly because Dolly Parton is really
[ __ ] good at giving away money like
she's really [ __ ] good at it I don't
know if anyone knows that she's
extremely [ __ ] wealthy and she's
giving away a ton of her money and so
because she's done it so well
Jeff Bezos is actually turning to her
just like Warren Buffett wasn't very
good at giving away money so he turned
to Bill Gates right he turned over
almost his entire Fortune at the time to
Bill Gates and said here you go because
Warren Buffett's like why I have enough
[ __ ] money I'll make it back yeah
yeah you know I mean I'll make it back
you you look and that's that is the that
is the very I mean a very uh you know
whether whether Jeff Bezos was visited
by [ __ ] Christmas Past or Christmas
or future it does seem like something
happened right something happened and we
also have to remember that even even uh
uh Mackenzie Scott right his ex-wife
um she has you know obviously an
interest in Amazon because of the split
that happened she helped and supported
Bezos while he was building Amazon so
she definitely has a stake in that but
we have to remember that she has been
able to offload billions of dollars from
her ownership and then make that money
back in the market so when people are
like oh we shouldn't tax billionaires we
shouldn't do this [ __ ] it they can make
the money back within and she literally
made the a handful of billions of
dollars that she gave away to these
Charities and made it back within less
than a week because of the market
which shows you that billionaires having
this money they don't need this money
because they can easily make this money
and other Investments and other things
they can acquire companies they can do
this they can make their money back
easily if you're a dumb [ __ ] idiot
though
and you decide hey London Trump Kanye
hey uh I can say what I want where I
want and no one can stop me and I need
money now the layers the Judiciary
Committee uh Jim Jordan tweets out from
their account three names Trump Elon and
gagne and those three of the
[ __ ] that have lost their
entire fortunes it was almost it was
almost like Jim Jordan had put [ __ ]
pins in the [ __ ] oh my little God and
was using it as a way to attack
the karma coming back at those three
names was amazing but but again you have
to remember that people like Donald
Trump and Elon Musk and all these other
people who are literally given that that
silver spoon of money to be like hey
here's money go do something right and
maybe you start a company maybe do this
maybe you you know defraud people
whatever it might be but there was an
overwhelming
uh pattern between these people
especially within the Trump family holy
[ __ ] I'm I'm doing a what was that on
this right now just based on the nfts
and you go through that whole family and
everything and I don't even get the
cover at all but like you go through and
you realize these people could have done
nothing they could have made their money
just sitting back and investing other
people in other companies and what have
you
but people like Trump people like Elon
they really do believe that
even though they're already rich they
have millions hundreds of millions of
dollars that they can then try to do
some sort of like get rich quick scheme
to make more money but what you find out
is that they expose themselves as liars
and frauds and degenerates
and yeah they make money but they're
making money off the backs of American
people like you look you look at the
Trump family they [ __ ] fleeced the
American people during the presidency
you had Donald Trump paying 750 before
750 zero dollars in 2020. there's a real
beer in there there's a real billionaire
pay only 750 dollars in taxes come on I
mean it's one is one of those things
where you really look at it and you're
like holy [ __ ]
Billy I mean like I knew this before but
like I I'm hoping for people now
realizing like
billionaires are not something that
should exist that much wealth should be
reinvested with it at least at this
point at least and people are like oh
socialism [ __ ] that dude are you telling
me right now if you were to compare your
situation to someone in another country
who has these these uh socialist kind of
programs in place that you wouldn't you
wouldn't [ __ ] love the fact that you
could go to school for free or you would
love to have uh free health care and and
benefits and this and that and you'd
have wait a second let's talk about
socialism yeah if you want to talk about
socialism Elon Musk is a perfect example
of it
guy guy was not natural born here in the
United States he's a foreigner to all
the moglodytes out there okay yeah now
the other thing too is [ __ ] on
SpaceX and Tesla has received gazillions
of dollars in our money government money
redistributed to him yeah to him
okay yeah oh yeah well well Tesla is a
privately owned or a public company who
owns a shitload of stock we found out
how much stock that [ __ ] owns
yeah and and he sold it he lost all our
he lost all our [ __ ] money that we
gave him right
speaking of redistribution of [ __ ]
wealth you you [ __ ] you you people
out there that do not understand the
distribution of wealth it doesn't matter
if if you if you [ __ ] consider
distribution redistribution wealth only
socialism because
wealth is distributed in capitalism too
you [ __ ] idiot how do you think it
works how the [ __ ] do you think it works
yeah and it really is crazy that we have
to fend off stupid arguments like [ __ ]
well you can't you can't give someone
the ability to not go bankrupt because
of a medical bill because Elon Musk
needs his socialism okay like well we
got enough [ __ ] money and he's got
enough [ __ ] money and he makes enough
money off our [ __ ] money obviously
that we could tax the [ __ ] ever
loving [ __ ] out of him and papers paper
people not to go broke because of a
medical bill we can do both things Elon
can be nice and happy and Rich and act
like he's smart when he's a [ __ ]
idiot and people can that are
hard-working Americans do not have to
worry to go broke over a [ __ ] medical
bill it is a thing that we can do we can
do both those things yeah and it's not
socialist to imagine that because Elon
Musk receiving all kinds of our [ __ ]
money to send [ __ ] Rockets up in space
and and [ __ ] build cards that
spontaneously combust I believe I
believe if we can do that type of
socialism we can do the other type of
socialism too I think we can do that I
think that's a possibility
um speaking of [ __ ] boxes I I got a few
stories I want to go over here because I
want to go to a special Christmas video
that's a friend of ours it's a friend of
ours okay I've tried to see if I get him
on the show today but I think his timing
is not going to work I haven't heard
back from him if he can make it in the
two hours
um you know what I'm talking about maybe
you want to send him a message if you
can get a hold of him um here is um
here's the story about Sean Hannity did
you see this story apparently he
testified
uh
yeah I briefly saw something this
morning yeah it was a Dominion voting
machines or systems
um you know they're suing Fox News yeah
for Dev amazing right and apparently in
this deposition of course it's under
oath Sean handed he has to say the shin
and wrote and the reason why Sean handy
has to say this [ __ ] is because he was
on Fox News disseminating the [ __ ]
defamation right he was part of the
defamatory lie that there was a that
there was a stolen election and Dominion
had something to do with it or some
stupid [ __ ] I mean it's it's bone-headed
type stuff Carey Lake type crazy Q Anon
stuff
um Jeremy Peters in the New York Times
has it here okay in testimony Hannity
and other foxes flocks Fox employees say
they doubted Trump's election fraud and
here's a quote
from Sean Hannity I did not believe it
for one second yeah now if you're
wondering because I was talking about
narratives and WrestleMania real life
and how the right wing is always done
the narrative and pushed the narrative
in the National messaging with lies yeah
here's a prime example of that Sean
Hannity when he goes in front of his
audience
still will say that the election the
2020 election was stolen he'll say that
[ __ ] yeah now he won't say this [ __ ]
about Dominion because he can't he can't
he can't say that it's because of that
he can he can have an opinion on his own
about right the whole
but by going into specifics about
Dominion then obviously yeah he's
he's a I mean
I don't know if he'll be protected by
Fox news if there's some sort of who
knows I mean maybe
through the uh kind of Discovery process
they revealed communication that said
from someone like Murdoch or someone
higher up that said hey push this
continue to say that Dominion was uh was
behind all of this voter fraud
now they could show that which means
that maybe that saves these people right
especially if you have someone like Sean
Hannity saying I did not believe it for
a second but the people upstairs told me
that I had to say it and maybe that's
him trying to or maybe it was Trump
given a phone call because you know you
know as well as I know John Hannity has
a direct line to Trump and if he ain't
got a direct line to Trump he knows you
to contact he was texting Mark Meadows
on January 6. telling Trump hey man you
need to cut this [ __ ] out this looks
[ __ ] horrible it looks like a coup
because it was that's why it looked like
a coup because it was and Sean Hannity
was complicit in it he was selling the
big lie and here is the evidence right
here Sean Hannity under oath folks went
to be deposed
for this this deposition of the
defamation case that Dominion has
against Fox News for 1.6 billion dollars
this isn't [ __ ] jump change this is
Alex Jones type amounts right of
defamation
and in the deposition under oath Sean
Hannity has to say he has to say it and
and the reason why I say gave it here's
what I believe there's evidence of it
there's evidence of him not believing it
there's text messages there's emails
something there is some sort of evidence
somewhere there's conversations that he
had with people somewhere inside Fox
News there is evidence that Sean Hannity
did not believe the big lie it was all a
bunch of [ __ ] but here's the thing
this [ __ ] is still pushing this
[ __ ] on Fox News and again I know it's
frustrating for the audience like how
the hell do they get away with it
because it's it's [ __ ] it's their
station yeah it's their media they get
to say whatever the [ __ ] they want I
mean they can be sued for defamation if
they're spreading lies I mean if I
spread lies here every day they could
[ __ ] people could sue me
but here's the thing
is that they are going to continue to do
this garbage and this is how their
narrative and this is how their
messaging works and that is the argument
that I have been making you gave Sanchez
have been making you know we had Rachel
bidikov or what all the way back in
January or February yeah at the run-up
to the midterms we were starting to talk
about strategic outrage then about how
Democrats have to have we we were even
we were still in the primary process and
and we were talking about general
election strategic outrage to make sure
that we saved our democracy and here is
why because their messaging machine they
do not give a [ __ ] about reality they
don't care the only time they care is
when their ass is in a ringer for uh 1.6
billion dollars yeah and that's just one
lawsuit you got the one against you've
got other ones that are against Mike
Lindell you've got other ones against
oan newsman I think Sydney pal um
Linwood another one that's under yeah
it's like they it's like I mean honestly
shooting fish in a barrel right now
because these people decide to continue
to push and even when they were proven
wrong they were like oh no we have
affidavits it's like those [ __ ]
affidavits don't mean [ __ ] when you
don't actually have ever who's who's
aphid and who's David I don't know
Giuliani with his leaking hair green
like we've got affidavits Ellis yeah the
list goes on and on and on here oh my
God and there's still every one of these
[ __ ] every one of these
[ __ ] are still telling the same
old [ __ ] lie they ain't telling it a
little different so that they can say
well I never believed that [ __ ] it was
just for entertainment value yeah it was
just for entertainment and it's like no
as a person as a as a elected official
as a former elected official politician
you know media pundit who has that reach
and that that microphone you can't just
be like oh well I didn't know I just saw
something and I decided to say it you
know it's like no what you you did was
you know it was defamation you you
stated something that was false about a
company with no actual proof or evidence
to actually back it up well who made
[ __ ] up and now you've got to [ __ ]
pay for it it's in their DNA though
right this is right-wing [ __ ] there's an
example and I'm not going to talk too
much about it because to be quite honest
with you George Santos this guy is where
in the world is George Central I mean
honestly honestly he's just another
[ __ ] Republican everyone's losing her
mind over this guy most most people
um in the district knew this [ __ ] this
[ __ ] was public that he was a [ __ ]
liar and they voted for him anyways
because he's a republican they love
Liars they [ __ ] love Liars because
they'll say the [ __ ] that they want to
believe and they need to feel good
because they don't want their [ __ ]
you know snowflake feelings hurt right
you know they got they gotta really make
sure that they don't they don't have
liberals out there pointing out facts
then facts you're scary they're really
scary like words and and dick pics of
Hunter Biden's [ __ ] they're really scary
I mean I really like them I love them
when they're on my thumb drive but
they're really scary this is really
stupid now Tristan Snell has this
breaking story of another [ __ ] lie
from a from this Republican George
Santos and really honestly the story
here is is that George Santos is a
Republican and that's why he's in this
situation yeah
I mean when I first heard that there was
a congress person that got elected and
his entire bio was [ __ ] my first
reaction was oh he's a republican for
sure oh 100 I didn't even left I didn't
have to look it up I mean you have to
remember you you had people like J.R
Majewski who was pretending Madison
gothorne these people like I don't know
Lauren bobert Lauren bobert's resume is
all [ __ ] man yeah it's all [ __ ]
I I don't know if uh
if these people
like did the Republican Party know that
these people were bad and like ah no one
will know no one will ever figure this
one and then and then all of a sudden
you're like oh [ __ ] they figured it out
I mean not that it took much but
honestly it's like No One's Gonna know
how are they gonna know how are they
gonna know it honestly reminds me of the
joke where there's like [ __ ] three
you know three kids in a trench Crow a
trench coat pretending to be an adult
and you open it up and that's George
Santos right it's like
he's not a real person he's got to make
a video there's there's a video right
there I I I I feel like I have to but I
just feel like he's it's like it's a it
feels like a cartoon character I mean
that's not to say that the Republican
party isn't full of cartoon characters
and jokes again you've got people that
are dining with [ __ ] Nazis you've got
people who are uh trying to grift money
on nfts you've got other because which
is stolen art by the way on Stolen Arts
stolen art Christ which doesn't ever end
with this gay which I I will say I told
Tony yesterday uh I discovered who some
of the artists the original artists were
that the artwork was taken you're
talking about the the people who they
stole from are the person who was
stealing the art the artist Clark
Mitchell stole artwork from places like
Adobe and Shutterstock but if you look
into where those images actually were
from and the artist that created them
because they sell them on show right
right an artist an artist a digit a a
digital designer our digital artist will
will create things and then sell them as
stock images right exactly and then you
can go buy the service and you can
either license the stock image or you
can purchase a stock image I mean
there's all sorts of ways but the big
the big problem with it is is they when
you go to these places there's there is
a certain licensing agreement that says
like okay you can use it for this or you
can purchase it the big problem though
is the fact that these images were well
one even there's an aspect of it where
even if they purchased it they're still
it's called derivative kind of art it's
called derivative artwork which is how
much they've changed it that you have
the way of which that you can resell it
without them saying oh they actually own
the copyright
but not only that
but this is something where they took
without paying the license for right
they just and then mastered the water
they just took the water marked and then
washed and washed it right and and so as
a digital artist you know he forgot to
clean up some spaces and because of that
you just why wouldn't you just buy and
license the [ __ ] throw his [ __ ] head
on there put the background in behind it
and just go on about your way how much
time and ever they spent washing these
images the the [ __ ] watermarks it's
ridiculous I mean you know it's not easy
to wash watermarks that's the whole
point of them but I want to go back to
this this this tweet here from from he's
just breaking George Santos also hit a
marriage this is going to sound familiar
hit a marriage and divorce to a woman
with the divorce coming weeks before he
filed for his First Congressional
Campaign yet he ran for congress
claiming he'd been openly gay for a
decade more lies and features from
Santa's man is a fraud so so he's doing
one thing saying another and then he's
doing a whole nother thing at the same
time
um this is republicanism like this is it
man this this George Santos the story
really is is that this is why we have to
[ __ ] keep yelling and screaming
because people like Sean Hannity people
like Trump with microphones they're
gonna tell lies and then you have
characters like George Santos that can
just tell lies and because it's all
normalized by these [ __ ] people
will vote for these pieces of garbage
and not think twice about it because
they got a [ __ ] R next to their name
because I've explained this before
the the power of Association
the power of Association is [ __ ]
powerful especially in our politics
because most people don't know a hell of
beans worth of [ __ ] about our government
our politics or the political parties
honestly if you put policies like actual
policies like we talk about here like
you don't want to go broke because of a
medical bill you want to have you know
you don't want to go broke because you
go to college or have a you know some
sort of degree after uh high school for
your career and you want kids to start
school at three instead of five I mean
you want to have a decent wage you know
you want to have a decent retirement you
don't have to wait till you're in your
until you're old as [ __ ] to retire you
want to retire when you're decently
young so you can actually enjoy your
retirement like all those things if you
put them in order
every [ __ ] one of these people who
consider themselves Republican would say
yeah I like that yeah I like that yeah I
like that yeah I like that oh Tony this
is a great list and you would go there's
only one party that's doing that yeah
which one is it maybe like oh it's
Republicans and that's the power of
affiliation because they have been
convinced that these people are who they
are not George Santos is obviously not
who he says he is and they don't give a
[ __ ] the people who voted for him do not
give a [ __ ] they only go off Association
and he's got an R next to his name
that's what they want and and it's been
made even worse this association thing
has made it been made even worse with
trumpism because it's even dumbed down
even more because he's [ __ ] boneheads
have been allowed to just run rough shot
with delusion all over our country sorry
I didn't mean to get out I didn't really
want to talk about George Santos too
much but it really I mean it is it is
right
well very on brand and we've seen it
again and again and again and a lot of
these things that we've seen even in the
midterms this isn't new it won't be the
last time they do it they'll try to
[ __ ] Hoodwink everyone else again
during the 2024 election I mean it's
just
the Republican Party honestly does not
have a platform that isn't just bigotry
and stealing money from you know the
middle class and lower class
all they do is they lie they cheat they
steal and they put people in power that
only further Empower their own party
through gentrification
uh gerrymandering redistricting uh uh
they do it through uh you know writing
new laws in the state of Georgia where
you can't hand water to someone in line
God forbid you know try to make it
illegal to vote
um after the
the Saturday after Thanksgiving
um all of these things these are the
Republican Party actively trying to
suppress people's vote well here's
here's another example of people they
put in here's another example of it Hugo
has breaking news here from the
transcript of Cassie Hutchinson's
testimony
wow he says the first Cassie Hudson
transcript about her interaction with
Trump or a lawyer Stefan uh passed how
do you say that passing teamsentino at
times reads like something out of a
mafia movie and sounds like clear
attempts to induce her
and to withhold testimony from the
January 6 committee so here is here's a
republican trying to tell someone not
don't lie just forget just forget the
[ __ ] that you remember because the truth
will be damaging to our narrative so
that's that's the two-pronged thing with
these [ __ ] is not only will
they [ __ ] lie and tell lies and keep
telling lies and and double down on lies
then they tell you don't believe the
truth and not only don't believe the
truth don't say that [ __ ] right do not
say that don't say the truth don't speak
truth you say the truth someone might
believe that [ __ ] and that's why
we try to say it here in a certain way
so that you get it delivered to you and
real in a raw way not [ __ ] with a
bunch of stats and a bunch of is that
the uh
I I and because it all kind of Blends
together is that the person that
contacted Cassidy Hutchinson uh well if
he attacks I'm not sure if that is the
lawyer but we did find out um so he goes
on here let's read this thread a little
bit because I yeah I'm trying to
remember if they did reveal who those
text messages were that were like oh he
appreciates your loyalty and all that
[ __ ] did they do that this is it
Hutchinson says here's the transcript uh
quote and this is from Cassidy
Hutchinson quote I had Stefan sitting
next to me and he never explicitly said
like you have to be loyal to these
people and if you're not then these will
be the repercussion but I knew the
repercussions I'd been in this world I
knew what I was subjecting myself to so
that was equivalent and we've talked to
Jessica Denson Jessica Denson is the
only person who has been able to knock
down the Trump the [ __ ] Trump NDA I
call her the Trump NDA killer
um and Jessica
talks about this [ __ ] a lot like look
you didn't [ __ ] with the and even
Michael Cohen talks about this right in
that way too like look because Michael
Cohen was one you did want to [ __ ] with
he was in Trump World he would come
after you he was one of he was he was a
fixer right well that was the name um
here's another quote that Hugo has here
uh from the transcript now this he
dropped this about an hour ago
uh he says Hutchinson says quote I felt
like I had Trump looking over my
shoulder oh
oh
how [ __ ] disturbing honestly I mean
like I you know it makes sense that that
feels that way like you've got everyone
everyone within the Trump World is
constantly backstabbing someone else to
platform themselves to a higher position
right they will [ __ ] turn on someone
in a [ __ ] instant Trump will easily
turn on his family if given the
opportunity to avoid any sort of jail
time or anything to that to that extent
we will easily see him push his son or
his other son or he's a [ __ ] attorney
his fixer right listen I I understand he
doesn't have any loyalty to his family
right but to the guy who was fixing
problems for him
fixing problems for him he [ __ ]
turned on that guy yeah listen you know
how loyal you have to be to be
considered a fixer in the world of this
Mafia type nincompoop Nazi stuff let's
listen to this here's another here's the
finish of the quote
from Cassie Hutchinson talking about
Trump she says because I knew in some
fashion it would be back to him if I
said anything that he would find
disloyal there's the word right the
prospect of that generally generally
scared me she was terrified of him I
seen this world ruin people's lives our
turn to ruin people's careers and I
don't know if she's talking about
Jessica Denson there or Michael Cohen
but those are the two that come to my
mind because I'm not only not only have
I interviewed them on air but I've
talked to Michael and Jessica
um off air and you know some of the
stuff that they said off air is kind of
like whoa [ __ ]
um because maybe he wouldn't but he
would definitely try to ruin their lives
and their careers he certainly would try
um he did it to many people he wasn't
successful all the time right but
um but again I mean this report has so
much I haven't even gone through it but
I've seen some excerpts here and there
and I just gotta say like
again you know they had to pick and
choose what they felt was like the most
impactful right you're you're telling a
story
and you're producing uh a whole segment
right or multiple segments rather but
you're producing a mini series to say
this is what happened on January 6th
this is how we got there these are the
things that led up to it this is what
they did after this is how they tried to
cover it up these are the people that
were involved Jesus Christ you got to
see this one this is two hours right
Ryan Reilly has this okay I don't know I
don't know what this is
but it says Cassie and it's part of the
transcript here right he's got the
transcript but here's he's given the uh
what do you call T T D L R the tldr TLD
too long don't read yeah too long don't
read but here's here's the short long of
it Cassie Hutchison is Q Anon aunt and
uncle
thought about refinancing their house so
she didn't have to go to back to Trump
World to pay her legal bills and she
begged her Trump supporting biological
father for help oh my [ __ ] god
that's how that's how [ __ ] scared she
was if she went back to Trump World
where I mean what Hugo is saying here
the quote
that it's Mafia style [ __ ] she would be
on the hawk she would be on the hawk to
Trump
see like this is stuff that we did not
see I saw I saw you know and I don't
want to call out attention to whoever
that person was but I saw someone that
had a comment on the previous uh
kind of rundown that you had from Hugo
and someone's like we saw these
highlights during the Jan six hearing
and I'm like I didn't hear anything
about this [ __ ] no this is [ __ ] crazy
we it covered the entire hearing yeah we
did 50 plus hours
of content production and I think we
know is that on it I've gone through all
the [ __ ] [ __ ] I've gone do you
remember do you remember the point where
Roger Stone first entered this like me
and I always had my my card I'm like
hell yeah I said something like yeah
baby that was like mute but it was it
was funny because it wasn't there was a
moment of silence and you you were like
oh thank you hell yeah
you know and then it went back to the
show but we were there we were there the
whole time right even though we weren't
on the screen we watched every [ __ ]
moment of that thing oh it was oh baby I
think is what you said yeah
you know someone did someone remember
that no that was me oh okay I didn't I
didn't I didn't know if you've seen it
in the chat because
Ben Marcellus text us and he was like
what was that I was like who said the oh
baby I was like I don't know I have no
idea you said that must have been
someone in the January 6 select room or
something that audio's really messed up
there Mr mizellis no I'm kidding I I
took the blame because it was me
obviously
um he didn't know that and it was funny
because the live chat was like who just
said oh baby
who just said that who just said that
like the whole the whole chat was like
who said oh baby did anyone else hear a
no baby
baby yeah because I was excited because
we were I was waiting for stagger Rhone
to enter the chat because we know we
were like okay we've got the proud boys
we've got Oath Keepers like we know he
was there and we know he's connected you
know that's a good point I wonder what
is gonna be about stodgerone in this
whole [ __ ] thing yeah has it been
previously released or had the Press
gotten like well I think I think they're
supposed to get you know they're I mean
it's gonna take a while to read through
this [ __ ] thing yeah it's gonna be
mounds and mounds of Mounds but they got
most of the transcripts last night
um yeah yeah but the entirety of the
report is supposed to I I think trickle
out okay so they're when I go to the
actual Jan six website it says release
of Select Committee materials uh today
December 22nd the select committee made
public additional transcripts of tests
of witness testimony that was gathered
over the course of the select
committee's investigation the January 6
attacks yeah so they're making sure they
keep the headlines by trickling So
Yesterday yeah so yesterday they were
they made public 34 transcripts of
witness testimony today they made
additional transcripts that were made
public so I don't know when the actual
report is going to come out I think they
said before the end of the year right
yeah well it's gonna hit this about the
same time as his tax returns start to
filter out right because we got the
report you read did you read the rest of
the report or did you just read the
first half uh no I haven't gone back to
it because I I'm trying to finish it
yeah but I'm doing another one on this
right well you you were sending me some
highlights of what you were reading in
report
um but uh so we should have we should
have is tax returns and they'll start
going through those and this all this
testimony and this evidence that they've
collected
um I was gonna do I was thinking about
well I was like oh I should do one on
the Jan like the the 10th day but I was
like 10 the 10th day kind of more or
less was like a recap nothing was really
new except like a few bits 10 days of
trees and what did you get for me but
then I look at this report and I'm like
oh that's gonna be the real nugget to
like crack open right right well I'm
excited for that one I know I know you
have a heart out today so I want to get
I want to get to the thing that I've
been waiting for
um I've been holding on to these videos
let me see if I can
um there's a couple of them here
is that no that's a different one
everyone knows we're friends with the
Walter Masterson he's a friend of the
show here I messaged him but what do you
think yeah yeah I didn't I didn't see
him he might be out and about doing this
very thing right now it could be well I
was I was um I was messaging this
morning I was like hey I'm gonna play um
some of your videos today I want to see
if you want to come on and
and talk to us about him this this is
the Christmas video that I've been
hanging on to I think he put these out a
couple weeks ago or is this from last
year I can't I don't know it's hard to
tell Walter does so much content from
last year but I could be wrong I think
this is new I think it is new because if
I go because he messaged me to share
that video yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well
he sent it to me I saw it on Instagram
too and I here's what I did I didn't
watch it because I knew it's going to be
hilarious but I wanted to play it today
and I wanted to play it with my actual
reaction yeah um because I'm because I
know it's going to be hilarious because
it uh let's see the the tweet that he
sent on he said look how New York City
is a racing Christmas and he's gonna
laugh face there are no decorations
anywhere okay now this is this is only a
minute long
um but this Walter does such a good job
at this I like we've talked to him
several times times
um and you can go actually to the
YouTube channel you find the um
just type go to the YouTube channel type
in Walter and that interview will come
up with him we did an interview with him
which I think we put the extended out on
YouTube I can't remember yeah like two
hours with this one day yeah I can't
talk and it was hilarious because he was
talking about the January 6
um Insurrection he was there on the ca
he was interviewing people well he also
I mean he would I was messaging him on
January oh well not January 6th I was
mentioning during I forget which one it
was from the selectarians but his video
made it literal Walter Walter Masterson
is evidence because we also have to
remember that uh that and you can also
hear it during the interview but Walter
was at another content Creator's house
in New York and the FBI showed up to his
friend's house and was like Hey to give
him Walter Masterson and he's like uh he
said at first he was scared as [ __ ]
because this is the FBI showing up at
his friend's house right and and his
friend was like how the [ __ ] did Walter
doesn't live here and they're like we
know and you're like yeah but we know
he's here we know but we know he's here
so and then and then Walter was like oh
got it uh this is in connection because
he had also shared he was like Hey look
I've got all this footage and I think
they came over to get more or they came
together yeah something well and he even
told us the story where he was standing
outside the Capitol and that's when he
heard that Ashley Babbitt he didn't know
it was actually Babbitt at the time I
don't think but had been shot and he was
like we're getting the [ __ ] out of he's
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] that's I mean he he
he and because people were piling out of
the out of the capital saying someone's
been shot someone's been shot because he
was there jolly good Ginger was there I
mean I know that Walter himself and also
our other the other content creator uh
it's a mutual friend they after what
they experienced they're like we went to
therapy like we had to kind of
sit and talk about what we had witnessed
because it was [ __ ] crazy it's not
something like they had come back there
was a video of them they'd come back
later that night and they were in the
car or the van and they're both [ __ ]
shaking right well you know the other
crazy thing is some of his content like
moglodytes had like oh it's a he's
antifa and he was he was the one that
it's like oh my God he started the riot
and [ __ ] because they're like goofing on
because they goof it's a goof well it's
all because it's funny you dummies it's
all because he has uh he's got the the
the microphone and on the microphone
he's got oan newsman right it looks
legit sometimes actually told him that
he had to stop using their right what
the hell is it called on the microphone
I lost it but just whatever the little
marker you can see the Fox News one yeah
yeah but that's the thing when they came
after Alex Jones and the other Infowars
people like we [ __ ] busted them these
guys were inside right and he's like
dude we and everyone was like you guys
are [ __ ] idiots they posted the day
the day after with the content he
literally posted on his YouTube channel
they're not they're trying to hide
anything Walter's like oh my God they
got me I already handed all this footage
over to the FBI
[ __ ] that's hilarious well let's watch
this piece of footage because it has to
do with the Christmas holiday as we have
the uh we're gonna be off for Christmas
four day weekend I wanted to play this
and this is I I just know this is going
to be good because it's Walter but let's
listen what do you think about them
taking away all of these Christmas
decorations throughout these blue cities
I think it's wrong I mean you know look
it's celebrating our culture celebrating
our way of life I feel like these blue
cities are trying to erase Christmas 100
yeah yes it's to me it's like it goes
through these blue cities and you don't
see signs of Christmas anywhere you know
how was the war on Christmas impacted
your life it hasn't there is no War on
Christmas what are you talking about
what are you talking about when you go
to New York and all these blue cities
you don't see Christmas decorations
anywhere
there's an angel right there
besides that angel
what else
I don't see anything that tells me it's
Christmas
did you see the tree are you okay
besides that yeah
especially here in these blue cities
that like it's hard to find signs that
Christmas Even is happening true I agree
please oh my God it's you know yeah so
so he does it a couple different ways
but Walter is so good at blending in
with these people that's one question I
had for him during that interview he's
like how do you [ __ ] how do you blend
in with him and he he told us I think in
that interview he was like well at first
it was I would do a lot of costuming
right yeah and he's like then I realized
it really wasn't about the costume it
was more like this attitude like this
yeah you know it's more about the
language and the attitude I I blend
right in they don't even know who I am
even though I do this and it gives
millions of views so thank you Alder for
the Christmas video I've been waiting
till today uh to play that and I'm maybe
we'll have Walter on next week and he
can yeah yeah yeah after Christmas you
know surely there'll be Christmas
decorations somewhere after Christmas
you know yeah you know I'm sure there
will be I'm sure there will be and I
know you got a heart out so here's what
we're gonna do everybody listen
bonehead of the week
today who should we put who should we
put well definitely definitely Elon Elon
yeah Trump for sure Trump uh uh who's
other candidate and maybe something to
do well before we go out let's there's a
video I sent you yeah with uh Jeffries
oh okay yeah we can play that
and there might be one of those maybe
one of the two people he talks about in
that video should do it right maybe it's
Lauren bobert maybe it's marjor Taylor
green this is only 47 seconds so let's
see if we can get a bonehead candidate
here let me pull it up here let's listen
and look at what is happening right now
look at what's happening right now
House Republicans are attacking Senate
Republicans
Senate Republicans are calling House
Republicans silly
and immature
the leadership situation
is in chaos
Marjorie Taylor green is fighting with
Lauren bolbert
and George Santos appears to be starring
in the sequel to catch me if you can and
it's not even January
the circus has already
oh [ __ ]
ing
craziness
versus Democrats Who deliver for the
American people I can't I can't tell you
how much I love this guy I'm so happy I
think it might be I honestly could be
George Santos I honestly Trump Elon
George Elon Trump George let's do it all
right let's do it let's put that up
we'll get that right after we'll get
that up sometime after the show so make
sure to go subscribe right now if you're
here on YouTube you can go to the
community tab you'll be able to you'll
be able to vote for bone hint of the
week as soon as that pulls up it will be
up on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod so go
follow our podcast page on Twitter at
Tony Michael's spot you can vote those
two places don't forget to download
every single episode of the Tony
Michaels podcast remember tomorrow we're
going to be off and Monday we're going
to be off we will be back next Tuesday
after the Christmas break everyone be
safe have a great holiday
and we will see you next Tuesday same
time same place Merry Christmas Surf's
Up [ __ ] you've been listening
to the Tony Michaels podcast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon